foreign
ose is joining us up first in Detroit
Rose welcome to the show
hi thanks for having me absolutely how
can we help
uh so my question is
um my my boyfriend wants to sell both of
our cars and get a truck and I don't
think that's a good idea but he said
it's for our kids safety so
I was calling to see what you think I
saw you sell the boyfriend hey
I'm kidding I don't know George I wasn't
fully kidding don't you guys need two
cars like is he saying why is he why is
your boyfriend wanting to sell your car
well he has a van that he drives for for
work
um that's paid off his car is paid off I
still owe thirteen thousand dollars on
my car but he wants to do it
um he wants to get a truck because he he
thinks it's it's best for the kids
safety and then he sits on a throne of
Lies he wants a truck because he's a
little kid inside who played with a big
truck when he was little and he wants a
truck
is that fair that's what I think I think
that he really he wants safety he needs
to get himself a minivan
here's the question was he specific
about the truck that he wanted because
this is gonna tell us a lot was he
specific
no not really no
the question still stands what is he
doing meddling with your finances yeah
good question
um what does this truck have to do with
your car is the big question
okay because so
honestly I'm not sure so I I drive my
car my kids are with me most of the time
and he tells me that
um you know for safety wise uh if we get
a car accident or anything like that he
thinks that having a truck is better
than having a Ford Escape so okay
um and then I still owe 13 000 on this
car which I know I could probably pay it
off by the end of this year and I want
to keep it until it's all paid off so
Rose you can do what you want to do girl
yeah you can do what you want to do and
you you what you want to do in my mind
is the best choice keep the car you have
and pay it off is there any reason like
logical reason because just a truck is
safer is is not a logical reason there's
plenty of cars on the road and didn't
you say a Ford Escape that's like a
mid-size SUV
yeah okay
um yeah what he's saying is bananas
don't do it what's your income I guess
I'm not bananas then no you're not you
are not okay good it's your car it's
your kids and until you're married and
sharing finances it's your money which
means it's your prerogative Rose are you
guys already have you guys combined
finances
not yet we are not married yet
um then he doesn't get a say in what you
do with your car if he wants to go get
himself a truck he can go get himself a
truck and let you use it sometimes
oh
I told him I said if he wants to get a
truck then he can get it everything in
his name and I can drive it that's fine
with me that's right Rose you go tell
him that and how have a little bit of an
attitude when you say it
give him the tube Rose is this do you
feel like this car is unsafe
I don't think so
um I I honestly don't like I said I I
still owe money on it and I just want to
pay it off and and keep it because I
I'm tired of paying for for this car and
and I know I can pay it off by the end
of this year and and by then I and it's
in 2018 so it's newer okay a great car
okay what's your income yeah
uh well I I was a stay-at-home mom this
past year but I'm starting a new job
next week and I'll be making about 40
000 a year awesome any other debt that
you have
uh three thousand dollar on a credit
card that I'm working on paying it off
and then and then that's it that's great
so let's attack that credit card first
let's knock that out free up a payment
and then we'll attack that car loan and
I totally believe you'll have this thing
paid off by the end of the year
yeah absolutely um okay can I just ask
one quick question sure um so both my
kids have one thousand dollars each
um that they got for birthdays and such
these past few years there's four and
six and I I don't know what to do with
it
I would just throw it into a 529
yeah okay just start putting it towards
yeah if it's if it's in if it's birthday
money or something like that I mean uh
that's unless they have unless they have
a purchase they want to make a little
small if they're trying to buy a toy or
a video game and they want to save up
and use some of that that's okay but
it's it's a great opportunity to teach
them to give save and spend we're going
to give a little bit spend a little bit
and save a little bit George saving a
whole bunch they're gonna look back at
that money and go I'm so glad I actually
saved that because now I can go to
college debt free now I have some money
to throw at my first car so it's a great
uh lesson you can teach them at this age
you're doing so good as a mom
oh thank you um so do I start uh an
account separate for each or combined I
would just do you could do separate
accounts and make them the beneficiary
on that and uh that'll that'll help
separate it when it comes time for for
college and it'll be in their own name
they'll have some skin in the game and
they'll be excited looking that at that
account going oh that's for me to go to
college debt free thanks Mom all right
okay sounds great well thank you so much
stuff for answering my questions uh that
really helped and uh you guys have a
good day thank you so much Rose
what a sweet woman I love Rose she is
sweet she's so nice her boyfriend he was
tripping he he he saw a nice little Rose
I can't imagine if I told my wife hey
and we're married combined finances if I
was like hey honey you want to sell both
of our cars because I want a truck for
safety oh gosh I I don't know Whitney
very well but something tells me that
wouldn't go over well she's not taking
that I don't know what it is about guys
and trucks I think we raise the
generation of the kids playing with the
big Tonka trucks I mean they're nice
we love a truck maybe it makes us feel
like in control I mean Dave drives a big
truck and I don't want to be in his way
on the road a true I'll tell you that
much let me real talk we used to live in
South Florida I mean pickup trucks
aren't really a thing there everybody
wants like electric cars we moved here
and I started seeing like Dodge Rams on
the road and like f-350s and I was like
this is nice there something came out of
me even that I was like I don't mind
this and then make matters worse we were
a one-car family we needed a second car
so my dad's like hey you can borrow our
truck it's a F-150 I love getting in and
out of it even though it's super old
what is it it's rock and roll I don't
know man what else trucks are one of the
main reasons American males are in debt
I'll tell you that much I mean those
things are freaking expensive they are
and they'll happily go into giant
payments for it under the guise of
safety yeah yeah no you know what's safe
not owing anyone anything okay and
driving a reasonable used car which are
just as safe as your shiny new car which
could be a Ford Escape in Rose's case
there we go you don't need to take it
mudding you'll be all right go with your
buddies who's in debt that's more fun